comment payer ses impôts sans douleur et
en douceur l'éternelle question refait
surface et comme toujours en pareil cas
on reparle du prélèvement à la source
déjà en 1973 l'assemblée nationale on
avait adopté le principe par le biais
d'un petit amendement
mais depuis aucune suite législative
n'avait été donné aujourd'hui donc
retour en force d'une vieille idée
l'harmonisation des fiscalités
européenne y est sans doute pour quelque
chose
claire chazal si la retenue à la source
était instaurée en france votre impôt
sur le revenu serait prélevée
directement sur votre salaire brut
c'est-à-dire déduit chaque mois sur
votre propre feuille de paye la france à
dr est ainsi une pratique commune à
presque tous les pays européens
la retenue à la source permettrait aussi
une perception de l'impôt immédiate sur
le revenu de l'année et éviterait la
fraude des salariés ce qui serait bon
pour la trésorerie de l'état
et puis l'impôt sur le revenu paraître
est moins douloureux assimile à une
cotisation sociale ce qui permettrait
aux pouvoirs publics de le relever plus
facilement mais les difficultés
techniques sont énormes et ont toujours
fait reculer les gouvernements premier
problème comment traiter les revenus non
salariaux ceux des artisans ou des
commerçants qui se rémunèrent eux mêmes
second problème les chefs d'entreprises
auraient à assumer seule le décompte de
l'impôt ce qui pour certaines pme
pourraient être très lourd à gérer
enfin comment le fisc assurera-t-il la
transition entre les deux systèmes de
perception de l'impôt sur le revenu le
ministère des finances semble en tout
cas plutôt réticent et il est peu
probable que la retenue à la source
puisse être instaurée dès le budget 80
ondes
[Musique]